[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro de paf
bienvenue aux téléspectateurs des télés
78 aux auditeurs de radio sensations
nous allons aborder essentiellement deux
thèmes évidemment nous allons revenir
sur la tragédie de rambouillet sur cet
attentat qui s'est joué vendredi où une
policière a été assassiné par un
terroriste et deux sont en ligne tout à
l'heure avec la maire de rambouillet
vers une matillon et puis on va prendre
aussi un peu de hauteur va parler de
l'espace de la mission conduite par
thomas pesquet et pour parler de tous
ces sujets mathilde obino bonjour vous
êtes communiquant tlf aînés qui plus est
et merci merci de nous rejoindre
laurent basauri bonjour bonjour c'est le
vice président de saint quentin en
yvelines et vous êtes maire-adjoint
d'elancourt et vous 07 16 et
jean-charles lajoie dit bonjour vous
êtes éditeur stéphane mention bonjour
vous êtes professeur à l'université de
versailles saint quentin il ya un
horaire de la faculté de droit et je
suis ravie et honorée d'accueillir
mustafayev tabou jour bonjour patron
vous êtes astrophysiciens vous êtes
chercheur au latmos vous avez vous étiez
le responsable scientifique de données
du satellite uv excuse at qui était de
lancer par space x comme la mission
pasquier et ovins évidemment parler avec
vous à voir votre éclairage sur 7 sur
cette mission on va tout de suite
prendre de l'altitude on va parler de la
mission pesqué
[Musique]
j'ai peut-être d'élire une première
question parce qu'on est très honoré
d'avoir un français qui commente cette
mission mais il faut rappeler que c'est
quand même une mission européenne alors
en général sur la station spatiale
internationale c'est un dispositif qui
fait environ
ces surfaces qui est assez grande et
c'est piloté par là par la nasa dans
l'es21 donc donc on a comme un couplage
avec plusieurs entités donc il ya la
force fédéral russe qui participe à ce
développement
vous avez l'agencé spatiale japonaise
ensuite il y a le canada qui intervient
et et en dernier lieu l'agencé spatiale
européenne donc thomas pesquet et un
astronaute européen qui fait partie de
la mission c'est pour ça que dans le
cadre de cette mission
quatre astronautes ont été mis en orbite
dont thomas pesquet il faut considérer
cela comme une fierté un honneur pour la
france d'avoir un astronaute français
qui fait partie de cette mission
bien entendu alors c'est intéressant
parce que pendant longtemps la conquête
spatiale a été justement une coquette
nationale ses dérivés un combat il veut
la guerre froide il y avait le combat
entre les états unis et l'urss et
aujourd'hui on voit au fond qu'une
coopération internationale très très
forte et en même temps une association
avec le privé puisque vous le disais
c'est super six qui a lancé claude ryan
alors oui c'est vrai que c'est une
société compagnie privée qui a mis en
orbite donc crew dragons 2 c'est
important de le dire par contre la
coopération internationale existe depuis
depuis 1957
donc il y avait une période de guerre
froide une coopération trop évidemment à
l'époque de l'union soviétique et les
états unis mais la france faisait aussi
partie de cette coopération
aujourd'hui on est sur quelque chose qui
est qui est légèrement différent nous
avons à la fois un nouvel enjeu
géopolitique pouvez constater
dernièrement on voit
la venue de la chine en tant que
puissance spatiale donc il ya des
intérêts géopolitiques et un autre
aspect important c'est c'est lié au fait
que nous avons à présent des enjeux
économiques
donc on voit intervenir des compagnies
privées comme spécisme est fortement
fortement financé par le gouvernement
américain
cela dit il ya toujours eu une
coopération entre enfin s'agissant
notamment des états unis entre la nasa
et le privé même s'il prévient alors
était pas aussi responsable par exemple
de du lancement que peuvent l'être et
l'homme ne sait sp6 aujourd'hui alors
initialement si on retrace l'historique
de l'ère spatiale bon initialement vous
savez il y avait des fusées v2 qui avait
été mise en place qui ont été récupérés
par entre parties parlées par les alliés
donc on était sur une application qui
était essentiellement dirigées vers le
militaire donc ensuite on a voulu
s'orienter vers la mise en orbite du
spécial met donc le privé était plutôt
en parallèle des gouvernements après les
enjeux d'aujourd'hui sont complètement
différent vous et distribué l'internet
un peu partout dans le monde
donc un enjeu très important au niveau
de la communication par internet
c'est pour cela qu'on voit intervenir à
nouveau ce p 6 mais aussi la compagnie
air mazen de jeff bezos et donne donc
les enjeux sont différents c'est le mot
je vais demander est-ce que vous avez
regardé un peu ces images parce que
c'était d'abord une qualité incroyable
quand de l'espèce vous avez regardé ma
tv n'ont absoluement le démarrage
l'amarrage et on la retrouvait
finalement lors de ses temps forts notre
regard d'enfant et en côte et
émerveillement également cette quête
spatiale on la retrouve
voilà c'est notre rêve d'enfant qui se
poursuit et puis finalement ces moments
de communion
ils sont assez rares à part les
compétitions sportives où on se regarde
on regarde justement avec adrénaline
avec enthousiasme voilà avec passion
donc ça c'est important surtout dans ce
contexte là donc c'est des moments
extrêmement forts et pour revenir à ce
qui a été dit à l'instant en effet c'est
une vraie conquête internationale et le
rôle de la chine est intéressant
justement par rapport au nombre
de fusée qui sont lancés aussi la
manière dont elle entend tisser un lien
avec la lune et les hanches et les
échantillons qu'elle a ramené donc une
grille de lecture qui est très politique
de la part des états unis et de la chine
c'est ce qui manquait à l'europe
aujourd'hui c'est vrai absolument
laurent mosar et vous avez regardé
oui j'ai regardé avec beaucoup de
plaisir d'autant plus que j'ai appris
tardivement que les tenues
vestimentaires des fifties astronautes
pour une fois avait été dessinée par un
styliste d'hollywood et donc je me suis
dit que là le privé était bien rentré
mais on doit d'ailleurs sur l'image qui
passe en ce moment on voit bien que on
est très proche de ce qui nous fait
rêver et un pour aller dans le sens de
ce que disait madame obino c'est à dire
que effectivement on s'inscrit dans une
forme de modernisation du spatial le
fait que tout le monde peut se
l'approprier
et puis je les regardais d'autant plus
avec plaisir que je suis heureux d'avoir
encore le droit de rêver à l'espace
parce que pour faire un petit hic je me
rappelle quand même qu'il ya une dizaine
de jours on m'a expliqué que les enfants
n'avaient plus droit de rêver que le
tout se rentraient maintenant dans le
fait de nous dire ce que croit en droit
de rêver ne pas rêver je pense à nos
amis d'europe écologie les verts les
amis je mettrai des gros guillemets donc
je suis très heureux qu'on ait pu faire
à nouveau rêver la population et du
spatial et cette concordance de temps me
semble un beau clin d'oeil à la réalité
de la vie où on vous a inscrit un stage
de rééducation à poitiers à la mairie
non il n'y a pas de problème on va vous
formater vos nouveaux rêves et plaisir
voilà donc foley mais cherche à vous
allez regarder aussi de huit mois c'est
effectivement je rêve aussi je trouve ça
absolument extraordinaire je trouve ça
très emballant et surtout ce qui
m'emballe c'est que il ya à peu près une
douzaine d'années quand le patron de spe
six à dix et moi je vais me lancer là
dedans je vais envoyer des fusées
non seulement je l'enverrai mais je la
recupèrerait tout le monde le dit mais
voilà encore il est temps de la nasa en
disant vous allez tous me disant mais
tout le monde l'a traité d'abruti de de
chou absolue et ses appuis la voilà
c'est la réalité ça marche il en sa
fusée il la récupère il envoie les crues
comme le dit très justement laurent plus
à l'heure mais on a fait revenir sur les
spécialistes auxquels yari mais il ya
d'autres choses qui l'on voudrait des
trucs
sur les tenues c'est génial enfin il ya
un décorum un look justement hors jeu
stéphane manceau civ ça vous apprécié
hommes
oui oui matricielle impression lors moi
j'ai pas regardé en direct parce que
j'avais j'avais piscine à ce moment là
ferrer et puis j'en suis presque à
regretter la trop grande qualité de
l'image je viens quoi il ya trois
lettres
quand je revois les images de juillet 69
jeu je me dis que ça fait presque plus
plus plus plus réaliste et là c'est
presque voyez c'est presque trop bien
les images des images de julia sion 69
faisait plus j'ai pas plus éloignés
presque plus mythiques là c'est trop
bien
oui on pourrait presque croire que c'est
monté que c'est fou il ya peut-être des
complots des complots disent qu'ils vont
se dire tout ça n'existe pas oui ce
qu'on a des points 9
vous savez mes fans elle loge de cette
mission cc c'est quoi alors la mission
alpha ses missions il y a d'abord il
faut savoir que ce sont des expériences
scientifiques qui vont être réalisés à
bord de la station spatiale
il y a aussi des opérations de
maintenance parce que comme je vous ai
expliqué la station spatiale c'est
quelque chose qui est énorme c'est 110
mètres de long de 75 mètres de large
trente mètres de haut ces 450 tonnes de
matériel et environ 1000 mètres cubes d
espace pressurisé
donc il faut un entretien le coup est
assez important pour ce genre de mission
c'est plus de 140 milliards
de dollars pour la station spatiale
internationale et donc il va y avoir
aussi des tests et des études sur des
cellules souches de cerveau ça permet
d'étudier notamment le vieillissement et
l'impact de laisser en microgravité
alors l'environnement spatial il faut
bien avoir peut-être que c'est quelque
chose de très sévères il ya des
bombardements de protons donc l'idée
c'est de vérifier un peu comment le
comportement humain l'homme réagit à un
ensemble de paramètres
donc il ya une multitude d'intérêts aux
travailleurs de cette mission est donc
encore une fois mon j'insiste il faut
aussi considérer bon j'ai vu le titre
c'est un honneur que quatre français
participant à cette mission
voilà est à noter que c'est le dixième
c'est le dixième spationaute français
qui a été mis en orbite un donc le
premier temps jean loup chrétien et lui
tôt pour la deuxième fois les reins
alors oui lui c'est son os et son
deuxième voyage alors il avait fait un
premier voyage en 2016 il avait été mis
en orbite avec une navette soyouz
donc depuis le sol russe
donc c'est le premier vol de
spationautes européens depuis le sol
américain depuis ces dix dernières
années et un petit lien quand même avec
la station spatiale il ya eu à un moment
où notre spationaute français qui
s'appelle léopold et art
donc il est parti en 2008 avec la
navette atlantis et ils ont mis en place
un module chez à noter le module
columbus donc c'est un module européen à
bord de la station spatiale
internationale et nous nous avions des
instruments qui ont été développées
justement à guyancourt notamment
l'instrument sur leur sol ce mec qui est
dédié à la mesure du soleil et du
spectre solaire
ah oui c'est celle de soleil absolument
justement non évidemment ces dix tout ça
est fascinant mais est ce que c'est bien
nécessaire d'envoyer à la vôtre dit on
va faire des expériences de sur la santé
notamment mais est ce que c'est bien
nécessaire d'envoyer des hommes et des
femmes dans l'espace
est-ce que les robots pourraient pas les
remplacer alors votre marque elle est
excellente
donc au début des années 1960 je
rebondis sur la remarque de stéphane
manson notamment lié au fait que en
juillet 69 on ne met plus régression le
premier pas de l'homme sur la lune
initialement pensé que la conquête
spatiale à leicester avec des humains ce
que l'on n'avait pas vu c'est
l'avènement de la robotique et de
l'informatique
donc oui beaucoup d'opérations peuvent
être réalisées par des robots mais ce
qu'on ne sait pas c'est comment le
comportement du corps humain va réagir
vis-à-vis de l'environnement spatial et
notamment on va s'intéresser à deux
choses et la future habitabilité de la
lune mais aussi celle de mars donc est
primordial que des humains participent à
ces missions et ensuite vous savez on
est dans un monde hyper technologique
avec de l'intelligence artificielle et
un tas de paramètres mais rien rien ne
peut remplacer un moment des décisions
donc c'est fondamental qui est aussi une
approche avec des humains ça c'est très
intéressant quand même parce que c'est
vrai qu'on pourrait penser que voilà
pourrait se placer au fond on peut pas
tellement se passer de l'homme un même
utilisateur sans signe c'est plutôt bon
signe depuis mi mai dans le but même de
la conquête spatiale qui est ce but elle
est habitée un jour ailleurs parce que
notre pays notre planète sera trop petit
il faut bien évidemment de toute façon
confronté l'humain à l'espace pour voir
comment il peut s'adapter comment il
pourra y vivre comment il pourra y
déployer un certain nombre de devis du
quotidien donc je pense que c'est
essentiel de tester des astronautes est
d'ailleurs la première expérience c'est
leur présence en ils sont eux mêmes
quelques pas des cobayes volontaires
mais des cobayes de cette expérience
spatiale
demain nous tous ici en tout cas nos
arrières arrières petits enfants
puissent aller sur la lune y vivre où
ils habitent et voilà je pense d'eux
eryl dans l'espace mettez de l'eau et
nous c'est un grand défi en tout cas
cette opération elle est très incarné
par thomas pesquet et on voit en amont
qu'il a fait un grand travail de
pédagogie avec les collèges avec les
écoles aussi donc ça c'est important de
continuer à tisser le lien pour
continuer à faire vivre ce rêve cette
conquête spatiale
des voleurs c'est la grande nouveauté
probablement l'astronaute que nous ayons
eu le plus communicants parce que les
moyens d'évoluer mais je veux dire il
sait se mettre en scène avec tout le
côté positif vous avez raison de le
signaler
on voit aujourd'hui nous envoie tout et
deux heures on a un tweet avec une
photographie enfin c'est absolument
actionnaires ce qu'on n'avait pas fait
si les plus anciens qui disent oui c'est
surtout lundi qu'en mai mais c'est comme
et quelques fois où il a laissé bêtement
sur cette présence de l'homme voilà dans
l'espace c'est important pour vous oui
bien sûr la piscine parce que au-delà
scientifique qui est petit est
indéniable des idées avancées
scientifiques que cela permet il ya
aussi il ya toujours cette idée de la
nouvelle frontière
on n'en sort pas alors même bien
antérieure à la formulation de cette
idée de avec kennedy il ya au fond
depuis depuis l'époque moderne c'est à
dire depuis la renaissance en qu'une 16e
siècle toujours cette volonté d'aller
passons pas forcément conquérir mais au
moins d'aller explorer et donc c'est ce
qui c'est ce qui contribue aussi sur le
plan philosophique historique
sociologique politique a à faire avancer
les choses
nous savons maintenant on peut imaginer
un jour des hommes qui vont sur mars
ça sent que ce soit plus de deux ans de
voyage alors la réponse est oui alors
bon je vais rebondir quand même sur une
deux remarques de certaines personnes
qui sont intervenues déjà il faut
considérer qu'il faut toujours rêver
c'est hyper important donc l'intérêt de
l'espace c'est que c'est quelque chose
qui fait rêver
ensuite le fait que l'on puisse habiter
mars
si une quarantaine d'années bon c'est un
sujet qui reste complexe parce que l'on
n'a pas abordé un sujet à savoir
l'éthique et la morale parce que c'est
éthique d'aller vers mars
ensuite un autre paramètre qui est
fondamental c'est que l'humain corps
humain n'est pas fait pour vivre dans
l'espace lors l'environnement est très
sévère social est dans l'espace ou ou
même sur mars et des problèmes liés à la
noce faire à la microgravité
pour avoir une idée on voit on va voir
apparaître un tas de problèmes
la modification de la circulation des
liquides biologiques la trophy du coeur
et ça c'est fondamental c'est pour ça
qu'on peut faire un parallèle entre
l'homme dans l'espace et d'étude du
vieillissement de l'humain mais il faut
considérer qu'aujourd'hui on a une
planète qui s'appelle la terre on doit
la respecter on n'est pas dans un
système avec des ressources qui sont
infinies nous sommes dans un
environnement avec des ressources
limitées aujourd'hui l'habitabilité de
mars il faut le considérer comme une
perspective
mais ce n'est pas la solution non c'est
pas la solution est là la pollution de
la terre peut-être elle à l internet à
l'idée qu'il faudra trouver une autre
planète il ya quand même alors un
certain nombre de gens qui disent voilà
bon c'est très bien dans mes baskets
mais au fond c'est l'arbre qui cache la
forêt l'europe la france sont pas très
bons en matière spatiale
est-ce qu'ils ont raison de deux
méthodes le doigt sur ce point pas alors
pour moi c'est complètement infondées il
faut considérer que la france et
l'europe sont excellents dans les
domaines scientifiques excellent aussi
au niveau de l' approche commerciale et
économique sur certaines missions
spatiales ont peut-être un peu moins de
présence sur la partie militaire
ensuite il faut souligner quand même que
la france est la troisième puissance
spatiale
c'est à dire que troisième état qui a
mis en orbite son satellite avec son
propre lanceur donc la france l'europe
sont et représentent des puissances
spatiales de très haut niveau
une question d'ailleurs donc je disais
vous est il responsable scientifique de
l'ue vs q7
là sur quoi vous travaillez aujourd'hui
il ya d'autres missions ivo qui vaut
peut-être voir le jour alors donc
lumesse puisse actuellement en orbite
donc d'abord il est endormi dans la
laverie qu'il faut avoir les résultats
déjà le 24 janvier 2021 alors la maryse
sage de croo dagen s'est faite le 24
avril 2021 soit trois mois plus tard
déjà on étudie les les données de ce
satellite 1 qui dédié à l'observation de
la terre au bilan radiatif donc on
s'intéresse l'accumulation d'énergie et
un mieux comprendre justement l'effet du
réchauffement climatique
donc on travaille évidemment sur une
nouvelle mission tout l'enjeu c'est de
pouvoir déployer des constellations
c'est pour ça que je parle et vous
parlez de l'europe et la france quand
même une des puissances spatiales de
niveau très très important donc notre
but à nous c'est de pouvoir mettre en
oeuvre une constellation petit satellite
et cette constellation peut être
déployée depuis la station spatiale
internationale idée de ce genre de
constellation c'est de pouvoir observer
la terre avec des multipoint de la multi
résolution spectrale mais aussi d'avoir
des multi variables temporaire
aujourd'hui l'enjeu c'est de pouvoir
observer la terre depuis tous points
pour pouvoir mieux comprendre les
différents constituants savoir
accumulation d'énergie température co2
méthane pour le climat l'environnement
présente aussi un enjeu clé aujourd'hui
oui c'est ça c'est ça qui vous
comprendre c'est que quand on envoie des
des satellites dans l'espace c'est utile
pour les pour les habitants de la terre
c'est ça qui comme pour tout parce que
nous confions utile l'insu thiam par
mètre cube et c'est qu'on vit dans un
monde qui est hyper technologique et
donc ça a des avantages mais
des inconvénients on est très tributaire
du cul ça fait vite donc la station
spatiale internationale par exemple ça
peut aussi permettre vous avez dit qu'on
a un instrument qui à bord et qu'il ya
la plus longue série de mesures c'est un
instrument français donc qui permet
d'observer le soleil est un des enjeux
c'est notamment d'observer les
évolutions et les éruptions solaires et
ça pourquoi c'est très important parce
que si nous avons des éruptions solaires
savons pas les anticiper il peut y avoir
des gros dégâts au niveau de
l'environnement
les satellites mais aussi de
l'environnement terrestre et juste pour
préciser terminer là dessus il ya eu un
événement important 1859 une mégane
tempête solaire
ç'a eu des conséquences dramatiques un
des télégrammes point qu'il détruit 5 %
l'ozone stratosphérique qui le porn qui
nous qui nous protège détruit plusieurs
années pour que ça se fasse titue et cet
événement peut se reproduire tous les
150 ans c'est dire qu'on n'est pas à
l'abri d'une mégane grosse éruption
c'est pour cela qu'on a besoin d'avoir
des observable depuis l'espace pour
aussi observer l'espace parce que
l'espace paraître un environnement
dangereux mais aussi pour la terre
absolument et c'est donc il ya une
dimension évidemment vrai mental c'est
parce qu'il ya des des écolos qui
condamne en effet aussi ces deux
symboles de l'espace mais c'est un
intérêt quand même pour l'heure pour la
vie sur terre
merci infiniment mostefa meftah de cet
éclairage et et j'espère va aura
l'occasion de revenir sur cette vision
parce que ils sont réunis sont là où
pour six mois ses offres à la durée de
la mission c'est simone et alors il faut
savoir aussi qu'être particularité c'est
que pour la première fois à français va
prendre le commandement de oui cette
station spatiale donc thomas ps qui
prendra le commandement de la station
spatiale lors de son dernier mois en
orbite et ça c'est une première
donc ça montre encore une fois que la
nasa les américains ont grandement
confiance aux européens pour pouvoir
piloter ce genre d'opération à vous de
vous libérer est ce que vous voulez vous
avez une question à poser
mustapha benbada alors moi j'ai une
question j'entends parler effectivement
de ses norias de satellites je sais
qu'il ya des programmes y compris
économique à et de développement là
dessus pour l'internet
moi mon inquiétude c'est toujours de
savoir est ce qu'on est capable de tous
les repérer pour être certain que quand
on envoie la prochaine fusée on va pas
percuter ces espèces donc on vraiment
ces cartes cartographier pour être
certain qu'on a pas des débris un peu
partout est-ce que vous avez des
éléments là dessus à nous communiquer
mais je vais je vais vous préciser alors
justement il ya une particularité quand
on a mis en orbite le satellite le 24
janvier 2021 143 satellites ont été mis
en orbite en même temps donc l'élément
clé c'est de pouvoir les suivre
donc on voit un moment suivant les
satellites qui sont des éléments vivants
mais aussi on va avoir un moment des
éléments qui ne sont pas vraiment qu'ils
vont devenir des débris faut savoir
qu'il ya une multitude de débris depuis
la première mise en orbite du premier
satellite artificiel en 1957 et ça c'est
un enjeu crucial
donc la nasa encore une fois les
américains avec la norad nous permettent
de suivre ces débris la france ou
l'europe développe aussi des systèmes
similaires donc on sait exactement où
sont situés les éléments dans l'espace
mais la multitude de petits éléments
génère une multitude de problèmes
c'est pour ça qu'on va voir apparaître
maintenant des dispositifs pour pouvoir
déplacer en orbite les satellites pour
éviter deux systèmes se percutent
vous savez mon dernièrement 2008
certains et en fait des tests vont
détruire des satellites c'est dramatique
parce que ça va générer dans l'espace ou
multitude de petits débris et ce qui est
vraiment dangereux sont là des petits
débris un petit des briques dans la
taille d'une balle ça correspond une
balle il est extrêmement dangereux et
donc il faut revenir à une chose
fondamentale c'est que il y a eu un
moment ce qu'on appelle le traité de
l'espace de 1967 mais appartient à
personne
donc la france elle-même essaie de
respecter des lois parce qu'on appelle
la loi des opérations spatiales
satellite lorsqu'il est mis en orbite
normalement ne doit pas rester très
longtemps de respecter une limite à 25
ans justement pour éviter cette
multitude de débris merci infiniment el
mustapha blesse pas de cet éclairage
ô combien précieux merci beaucoup et à
très bientôt alors pour parler
évidemment de cette mission et puis
aussi de ce que vous faites notamment au
latmos avis en cours cette conquête de
l'espace à laquelle vous participez
merci infiniment merci au revoir
alors de l'an passé au deuxième deuxième
thème de cette émission qui est un thème
évidemment qui fait moins rêver qui est
beaucoup plus grave c'est de le retour
du terrorisme avec cette tragédie qui
s'est jouée à rambouillet vendredi vous
savez une policière était égorgé par un
terroriste c'est le deuxième thème de
cette émission
[Musique]
donc on va revenir sur cet attentat de
rambouillet vendredi il ya plusieurs
choses intéressantes d'abord les
yvelines il le département peut-être
debout touchés par le terrorisme
alors c'est une triste réalité et
magnanville il ya eu l'assassinât de sa
nouvelle bâtie il ya eu des événements
année en programmant nos multiples
causes d'abord il faut se rappeler que
les wings et le département de france
dans lequel il eut le plus des départs
vers le djihad ça tourne devine qu'ils
sont proches et qui appartiennent à
saint quentin en yvelines ont vu un an
départ par rapport à ça donc on voit
bien que les théories jihadistes ont ici
un terreau fertile probablement plus
qu'ailleurs
comme quoi c'est pas forcément seine
saint denis en même temps il ya
également à côté exemplarité des
yvelines qui fait que c'est une cible
aussi intéressante je pense quand on
veut on veut créer l'émoi l'effroi ce
qui est quand même ce que les que les
théories de tout poil recherche c'est
plus intéressant d'aller frapper dans
les yvelines que d'aller frapper
probablement dans la creuse encore qu'on
n'est pas protégé plus heureuse que dans
les yvelines
on voit bien que oui on est à la fois d
un département de départ de frustation
des idées mais également une cible par
rapport à tous les symboles que présente
la qualité de vie dans ce département et
on trouve toujours à peu près la même
démarche c'est à dire 1 1
un personne qui se radicalisent dans les
derniers moments qui passent au travers
d'aidés des radars delà de la police
c'est vrai que c'est toujours un peu le
même le même processus
et encore une fois les forces de l'ordre
évidemment qu ils sont les victimes de
cet attentat
mais oui parce qu'il est effectivement
troublant inquiétant hyper angoissant
c'est que n'importe qui maintenant se
transforme en terroriste il ya plus
besoin de ces sommes colossales pour
monter les attentats y a plus besoin de
cette organisation sont des sorte
d'électron libre qui se radicalise tout
seuls dans leur chambre
enfin tout seul pas forcément tout seul
mais tout d'un coup le passage à l'acte
y'a pas assez rapides et voilà que quand
on voit le coût des attentats qui
diminue de jour en jour enfin maintenant
ça ne coûte plus rien de faire un
attentat c'est une comptabilité sordide
mais il ya un universitaire je crois
qu'il est écrit un bouquin vraiment
intéressant sur le coup des attentats et
d'idoles entre eux entre le coût des
attentats sur le aux états unis sur les
sur les tours jumelles et par exemple le
coût de l'attentât à nice qu et voilà je
veux dire c'est sa baisse du du du
centuple et maintenant ça coûte rien
quand je veux dire type achète un
couteau à un couteau de cuisine
donc c'est ça aussi qu'il faut prendre
en compte et qui est extrêmement grave
et effectivement que faire contre ça
mais effectivement c'est surveillé
surveiller surveiller et bien évidemment
on va entendre une nouvelle loi qui veut
qu'ils pas paraître en parler après la
réaction évidemment on a toujours ce
sentiment comme sa puissance et même
d'incompréhension sur quoi est il ya un
vrai sujet en effet les yvelines sont
été le théâtre d'attaqués
c'est le vrai risque c'est la
banalisation avec des formules toutes
faites qu'on répète les politiques se
rendent sur place
donc ça c'est un vrai enjeu on voit que
ça a été la police qui a été attaqué
frontalement qui en première ligne qui
se dévouent au quotidien il ya un vrai
sujet c'est la responsabilité des
politiques la manière dont ils vont
nommer les choses c'est une attaque qui
a été fait contre la police par des
islamistes par un islamiste en
l'occurrence et donc c'est un vrai sujet
de nommer la réalité telle qu'elle est
sans détour sans lutter
c'est important de de montrer tel qu'il
est et de d'expliquer aussi sa totalité
la et en affrontant véritablement le
problème en on est en étant capable d'en
parler à froid et en trouvant en
véritablement des solutions et donc aux
acteurs qui souhaitent être en
responsabilité qu'ils le sont justement
qui voit là il ya ce rôle et ils sont
attendus aussi sur sur ces sujets là
c'est votre maison tout ça c'est de
toute façon c d ce sont des questions de
long terme
c'est une une lutte une lutte de très
longue haleine et il faut se garder de
toute surenchère de toute surenchère
qu'on voit tellement à chaque fois
surgir temps à droite avec cette
obsession cette obsession permanente de
l'étranger que pour une certaine gauche
avec le fait que les questions
sécuritaires ce serait des questions de
justement droite ya une ligne de crête
qui est assez délicate et qui doit me
semble-t-il être être empruntés être
maintenu avec grande prudence grande
vigilance et grandes consciences par le
pouvoir politique quel qu'il soit oui
c'est vrai qu'on a entendu alors des
réactions politiques
alors évidemment un marine le pen mais
aussi dans la droite républicaine visant
il faut faire plus de lien entre
l'immigration et le terrorisme
on pourrait peut-être avoir une
politique de prévention plus forte
est-ce que ça c'est pas un peu du coucou
revoilà vous avez bertrand maintenant
une peine de cinquante ans ce qu'on
n'est pas un peu dans le concours lépine
de on ferait mieux si on était au
pouvoir
alors que tout le monde sait que c'est
quand même très compliqué enfin c'est
quand même bien d'abord d'avoir l'idée
d'essayer de faire mieux plutôt que de
se dire bah oui c'est comme ça et puis
on laisse tomber
donc c'est très facile de parler de
concours lépine des idées contre le
terrorisme moi je
j'appelle ce concours lépine parce que
je veux dire si un jour on arrive à
trouver une solution aussi bien parce
qu'il y ait des gens ont réfléchi
ce qui me choque un peu c'est que tout
le monde parle d'unité nationale et puis
dès qu'on est des cons osent émettre une
critique sur sur la politique actuelle
du gouvernement on est tout de suite
extrême droite de droite
on n'a pas le droit de parler bah si on
a le droit d'émettre une idée on a le
droit de dire que peut-être la lutte
contre le terrorisme pourraient être
menées différemment peut-être le le
l'étude des populations à risque
peut-être les les flux de déplacement
vers l'est vers la syrie c'est ce sont
des pit et il ya des tas de gens dans
les ministères au gouvernement qui ont
remarquablement bien leur boulot il ya
des dizaines d'attentats qui sont des
jouets il n'empêche que quand il y en a
un qui arrive jusqu'à jusqu'à samson
d'accomplissement c'est un drame absolu
et que c'est normal que les hommes
politiques sans être d'extrême droite et
le droit de dire c'est pas absolument
comme ça que nous ferions
ils ont le droit et c'est normal c'est
ça la démocratie va toujours balayé le
truc qu'on a ou la la il ya un mort ne
vais pas le droit de parler bah si on a
droit de parler justement parce qu'il ya
un mort véronique matillon vous êtes en
ligne avec nous vous êtes la maire de
rambouillet oui bonjour bonjour bonjour
merci merci d'être avec nous évidemment
le tout le monde était surpris vous faut
qu'un attentat se déroule dans une ville
qui est réputé au fond pour pour son
calme pour sa tranquillité
quel est l'état d'esprit des deux des
habitants de rambouillet aujourd'hui
alors écoutez c'est un ami la death trio
d'émotion déjà très très grande émotion
je vois que les rambolitains sont encore
sous le choc et ont du mal à réaliser
mais d'un autre côté c'est aussi mon
rôle est aussi de leur dire combien nous
devons continuer à croire à
l'attractivité de notre ville parce que
ni nous avons été frappés par ce cet
attentat n'est que ça aurait pu arriver
n'importe où c'est un commissariat ça
s'est passé dans un commissariat comme
ça aurait pu se passer dans un autre
commissariat dans une autre ville ce qui
a été ce qui est atteint c'est ce sont
les valeurs de la république
à travers cela c'est un bide à
rambouillet et en effet c'est pour une
ville comme la nôtre qui lit
tranquillement d'habitude eh bien oui
c'est vous le versant est
c'est un état de choc mais est ce qu'on
disait tout à l'heure c'est à dire qu'il
ya une radicalisation assez rapide de
des terroristes son père vivait à
renvoyer l'un c'est bien ça oui mais
évidemment voilà c'était très difficile
de savoir quand un individu notamment
avec le confie demande d entraide ses
yeux comment il sera aidé cali c'est
très compliqué à savoir c'est vous ne
parliez de l'émotion de
des rambolitains et
certains demandent aux phoques est un
hommage qui soit organisé pour cette
pour cette policière vous vous y seriez
favorable nous faisons un rendons un
hommage en fin d'après midi à 17h30
un hommage est organisé au niveau de la
mairie de rambouillet parce que
évidemment il n'était pas question de ne
pas rendre hommage à leur mort en dont
bien sûr hommage à stéphanie mais à
travers l hostie à tous les policiers
puisque c'est aussi ce symbole qui a
voulu être atteint mais c'est important
de leur dire notre soutien parce que
aujourd'hui nous sommes encore comme je
vous le disais sous le choc c'est encore
le deuil nous devons respecter ce deuil
de la famille des proches de stéphanie
n'est aussi de ses collègues qui sont
bien entendu extrêmement atteints par ce
qui c'est passé et les policiers de
rambouillet le commissariat de
rambouillet c'est une c'est une vanille
notre police mme pas le travail très en
lien même à la mairie sommes très
attachés à ces liens permanents et
devons les soutenir et les soutenir dans
la durée alors parler du commissariat de
rambouillet c'est vrai que les policiers
sont la cible favorite on l'a dit des
terroristes alors ça n'est pas
évidemment de votre compétence mais
est-ce que vous souhaiteriez que
peut-être les lieux où travaillent des
policiers les commissariats notamment
soient mieux protégés en effet ça ne
relève pas de mes compétences je pense
que l'état va en tirer aussi les
conséquences et les ministres se sont
dépassés les administrés
monsieur darmanin sont venus sur place
se joue dit je reste dans mes
compétences
évidemment tout ce qu'il faudra protéger
nos policiers
mais là en effet c'est le commissariat
ce sont les policiers qui m'ont été
visés mais je pense aussi à toutes nos
forces de sécurité la gendarmerie à
rambouillet se situe non loin du
commissariat
ce sont des hommes en uniforme et je
pense également à nos services de
secours les pompiers qui ont eux aussi
interviennent au péril de leur vie
aujourd'hui parce que nous savons ils
sont aussi la cible d'agressivité donc
c'est un ensemble de deux services de
sécurité que nous devons absolument
protéger au mieux le si vous avez un
message à faire passer à vos administrés
vous l'avais un peu 10 et ses voiles à
garder garder l'espoir le recueillement
évidemment l'émotion et puis elle
gardait l'espoir quand même bien sûr
garder l'espoir restait unie parce que
c'est en étant unie que nous sommes
forts et nous allons continuer à faire
famille
si je puis dire pour affronter ce qui
vient nous arrivait nous ont relevé
parce que c'est aussi rendre hommage à
la fois stéphanie à la fois sa famille
est à la fois ces collectes de lait
souvenir d'être forts de votre côté pour
pouvoir les soutenir
merci infiniment d'avoir avec matignon
je rappelle donc lundi 17h30 hommage à
stéphanie cette policière dont qui a été
assassiné vendredi par un terroriste
d'origine tunisienne merci infiniment
madame le maire merci à vous à thé do
minho justement orange revient à ce
qu'on disait précédemment la merde dit
dans un message d'unité on voit que la
classe politique
aujourd'hui n'hésite pas à se diviser
sur c'est sur ces questions est ce que
c'est un bon sujet de division justement
aux deux débats il ya plusieurs
temporalités en effet va à la suite de
l'annoncé évidemment le temps de
l'émotion du recueillement aussi après
il ya des décisions et des échanges et
des débats politiques parce qu'on est en
démocratie parce que c'est bon et
effectivement il ya cette grille de
lecture c'est 2022 c'est les régionales
aussi donc ça va être important aussi de
ne pas tomber dans une surenchère avec
les uns et les autres qui vont se
positionner et voilà d'avoir une recul
aussi par rapport au positionnement par
rapport à cet événement dramatique
également non mazauric moi je suis pas
choqué qui est du débat
je suis même pas choqué qui est de la
surenchère d'ailleurs parce que pour
être le sens de ce qu'on disait tout à
l'heure face au terrorisme et face à
tous les problèmes que nous avons en
général il faut bien que l'ensemble des
forces politiques s'affrontent sur ce
thème là qu'ils en sortent d'alors un
vainqueur dans une élection est un
vainqueur c'est d'abord et avant tout
choisir un programme
derrière l'homme et le côté marketing ou
la femme ce qui est le programme qui
compte
et moi j'ai envie de savoir ce que
propose des uns les autres pour faire
mon choix est d'ailleurs pour matière
mon adhésion aussi dans un permis si
j'adhère à parti politique c'est mon
choix c'est parce que je conserve son
parti porte au mieux les idées qui me
semblait plus adéquate et en matière de
sécurité il ya des vrais choix je dirais
d'ailleurs que avant même de condamner
il faut savoir ce que l'on ferait des
gens qu'on condamne donc est-ce qu'on va
consoler places de prison combien on va
en construire parce que c'est trop
facile aussi accusé les juges de libérer
une partie des gens quand en fait ils ne
peuvent pas neutres sont les emprisonner
donc ce soit le juge d'application des
peines d'ailleurs où l'addition de
première instance dont il ya les vrais
choix politiques des vrais enjeux moi
j'ai envie de savoir ce que pense
extrême gauche la gauche la droite pour
choisir
voilà et je pense que c'est pas mal ça
d'ailleurs que des élections arrivent et
qu'on dise oui c'est parce que l'ère des
actions mais c'est bien le prince
ips il ya des élections c'est justement
pour que des programmes soient mises en
place et pour que d'autres ensuite les
applique et donc je trouverai toujours
un peu et c'est un peu facile parce
qu'on dit il se déchire non ils
s'affrontent avec des idées différentes
avec des idées mais pas des petites
phrases faut un temps long quand même
d'installer des programmes de diffuser
pour l'impression que ces deux versions
alors si je comprends ce que dit madame
obino sauf qu'on est dans le mode
d'aujourd'hui de la communication rapide
on est dans le tweet on est dans la
phrase qui doit marquer et c'est un art
de clarisse est passé relativement peu
exprimés donc je vous parlais pas
s'exprimer non mais marine le pen elle
n'a juste que rien à faire halak la
grande classe et puis de toute façon
elle encaissera l'a fait jusqu'à ce que
stéphane manceau est ce que justement la
droite républicaine en reprenant il ya
la vieille phrase de jean marie le pen
les les français préféreront toujours
l'original à la copie
est ce qu'il n'ya pas ce risque là quand
même de faire monter leurs bleus
national en prônant des thèses qui lui
sont pas très étrangère vous savez on
retrouve ça parfois dans le dans
l'expression conquis assez souvent
utilisée aujourd'hui faire le jeu de wii
vous ne pouvez pas dire telle chose
parce que vous faites le jeu de alors
faire le jeu de en traduction simultanée
si j'ose dire ça veut dire taisez vous
vous ne pouvez pas vous exprimer sur
cette question là alors moi je rejoins
ce que je disais jean-charles tout à
l'heure c'est à dire qu' il ya des
questions dont il faut parler et laurent
mazaury aussi la raison c'est à dire que
on peut et on doit parler de de toutes
les questions importantes importante
dans la mesure où elles importent aux
citoyens et elle importe aussi à
léquilibre à la paix civile qui doivent
être maintenus au sein de la république
mais ceci faisait on peut aussi en tant
que citoyen porter une appréciation un
jugement sur le niveau du discours
politique alors on a la classe pour
l'équipe qu'on mérite puisque il s'agit
de voter délire mais moi ce que je sais
que je n'apprécie pas dans ce genre de
circonstances c'est si vous voulez la
fâcheuse impression d'être pris pour un
abruti c'est à dire qu'on vienne
m'expliquer que des gens qui
aspirent à exercer des responsabilités
plus ou moins importantes viennent
m'expliquer à quel point les choses
serait simple si elle était au pouvoir
ça je n'apprécie pas je n'aime pas être
pris pour un crétin et je pense qu un
certain nombre d vu aujourd'hui prennent
des électeurs pour des abrutis et qu'il
est aussi dans le rôle d'aider des élus
dans le rôle des politiques en général
même si je n'aime pas ce terme là que
d'aller parfois contre le sens du vent
et contre l'opinion dominante et c'est
le seul homme politique ou la femme
politique digne de ce nom n'est pas un
bouchon qui est ballotté au gré des
flots et au gré du vent
il y a une idée d' éthique de
responsabilité qui fait hélas souvent
défaut dans la parole politique telle
qu'elle est portée dans ce genre de
circonstances quelques vrais liens
d'accord que ce que dit stéphane je
reviens juste une minute sur ce que vous
disiez de 20 ans que la droite
républicaine ne ferait pas le jeu du
front national je pense que c'est plutôt
la cécité de certaines personnes à
gauche et certains partis politiques de
gauche qui font du livre du
rassemblement national que la droite
fasse dire que ça ça me paraît un
glissement intellectuelle curieux après
stéphane raison de dire incident oui
c'est un force de dire qu'on va faire le
jeu et finalement je n'y peux rien dire
ce qu'il n'a pas de solutions de fleet
fou aucun parti politique mais
propriétaire des idées qui a pu le
rappeler ces idées là elle tu rentres
ensemble ensemble des partis c'est comme
si on disait que si on parle d'écologie
donne en fait le jeu de l'écologie moi
j'ai plutôt tendance à dire que quand on
parle d'écologie on vide deux parties
cogic de sa substance et comptoirs de
sécurité ou de laïcité
merci c'est passé de mode mais une
époque je vous rappelle que quand on
prononce le mot laïcité on était axé
crack de front national ce qui connaît
même juste hallucinant mais je trouve
que on en est sorti parce que justement
les partis et les hommes et femmes
politiques et de citoyens s'est ré
approprier la notion de laïcité donc il
faut parler de sécurité faut parler de
justice on a le droit de se poser
surtout on va pas être dans un pays dans
lequel on peut à la fois fabrica et
capturer se dire qu'on n'a même pas le
droit de parler de tout et moi je trouve
qu'on ne fait pas le jeu et que bien au
contraire c'est quand juste
montre ses propres sites et que l'on
vient en affrontement ne pas faire le
jeu c'est au contraire combattre parce
que sinon on abandonne dépendantes hier
certains partis et il ya encore une
partie du droit de respirer le parti du
bonheur partie de la joie alors je suis
pas joyeux parce que tel parti a dit
qu'il fallait pour eux
aimons nous tous non je pense qu'on ne
fait pas le jeu je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec ce qui vient d'être dit au
contraire on combat mais positivement en
montrant qu'on n'est pas on n'est pas
complètement autiste de ce qui se passe
et qu'au contraire on représente la
population dès maintenant l'idée
vingtaine de vidéos il ya un sujet
justement par rapport à la prise de
parole du politique qui bien souvent est
diluée parce qu'ils veulent être
uniquement dans un temps extrêmement
court pour être prêt dans les chaînes
d'information en continue aussi et donc
du coup on est loin de vraiment cette
pensée qui est complexe aussi et donc il
ya une vraie attente pour être mieux
représentés pour être mieux entendues et
pour être davantage audible et ça c'est
un vrai sujet aussi pour les
présidentielles les communique vous
pourrez peut-être leur dire que les
français attendent peut-être aussi un
peu plus de raisonnement plutôt que des
petites phrases et ça c'est un vrai âge
est associé à un changement là dessus je
prends le temps des petites phrases des
réactions non je trouvais pas non c'est
juste que on est on est des français et
que donc si c'était vrai expert qu'en
réalité en même temps on dit oui on veut
des chevaux du fonds il faut du fond du
fond et puis alors qu'à l'audience de
l'émission dal'ouna tâche paraît de
chapa nous propose c'est ridicule mais
ridicule en même temps tellement
révélateur c'est exactement ça sert
qu'on veut du fonds et si vous faites
une vous mettez à 20 heures tout à
l'heure 21h pardon parce que entre temps
les émissions ont glissé à 28 mai revêt
été une bonne émission et du fond vous
ferez une audience catastrophique
mettez une émission dans le cas il ya
que des petites phrases et auto monde se
dispute le règlement d'audience mais le
lendemain ce qu'on regarde et diront
c'est un vrai scandale cette émission
y'a pas le font toutes parts on le sait
tous très bien malheureusement entaché
le journal pour les questions de fond
dans la tête aussi pour les gros titres
puis on regarde bien et fait dire à la
barre des sondages qu'est ce que vous
voudriez comme les missions et les
j'aurai pour des à 80% des émissions
culturelles
jahier il y avait 2 % dresse contre la
sienne ça devient qui est exceptionnel
donc et puis du fond il y en a partout
on peut trouver on achète le journal
cette news magazine achète le point on
achète love sont à chaîne du fond il y
en a des hommes politiques ils font des
petites phrases pas ce qu'on leur
demande et parce que ils vont être
repris et c'est très bien ils vont être
écoutés et puis après on a envie d'aller
plus loin on va là où il s'exprime en
long et en large et sur des quinzaines
de feuillets quand il ya un interview
d'un homme politique dans le point du
fond il y en a ici en a pas c'est parce
que le type a pas de fond mais c'est pas
parce qu'il peut pas exprimer
donc voilà des puits des petites phrases
des paroles visiteurs en train de dire
que c'est scandaleux que et que xavier
bertrand réclame 50 ans de prison au
moins c'est une idée après on peut
débattre on peut dire est ce que c'est
faisable pas faisable mais au moins
c'est pas une petite phrase c'est une
idée qui fait sourire ses fans oui non
mais je comprends très bien sûr pas
d'accord mais en toi en tout cas c'est
une idée c'est pas une définition assez
mal c'est grotesque
de mon point de vue en tout cas c'est
une petite phrase voilà mathilde et puis
après on passe à 3 l utiliser oui deux
petites choses fallait chercher les
publics là où ils sont donc ça st c'est
un vrai sujet aussi pour les électeurs
prescripteurs aussi mais il ya un risque
aussi pour les politiques de 200g aussi
il reste des responsables politiques
ils ont ce costume là qu'il faut qu'ils
endossent qu'elles se soient les
circonstances quelles que soient les
contextes aussi et ça c'est important
ne pas surjouer ne pas sûr signifier
aussi des rôles en allant sur tweets ou
tel ou tel outil de communication à
destination des jeunes
alors on va parler de la situation
sanitaire mais j'ai quand même il ya une
question vous n'avez pas prévu d'aborder
mais je voudrais quand même oeuvre juste
votre sentiment
il ya une grande manifestation
en faveur du vin contre le fait que le
l'assassin de manama dhimmi ne soient
pas jugés
qu'est-ce que vous comme ça qu'est ce
que vous en pensez vous c'est que c'est
un déni de justice que c'est oui c'est
une décision curieuse je comprends que
ça choque bien évidemment la communauté
juive mais surtout moi ça me choque
pareillement et je comprends que tout le
monde peut choquer après stéphane
manceau va sûrement nous expliquer il
aura raison que s'appuie sur des points
de droit puis mouiller irréfutables bon
ça c'est tout à fait vrai mais l'émotion
on peut la comprendre et c'est assez
compliqué l'arrêt de la cour de
cassation parce qu'il ya deux choses
notamment alors ce qui est vrai c'est
que généralement quand je sais pas quand
vous faites un infraction que vous avez
bu ou fumé circonstances aggravantes
là c'est plutôt voilà trois aspects moi
je vois deux aspects principaux le
premier aspect près que je vois c'est
tout d'abord que à la fois on nous dit
que c'est un crime antisémite
donc j'ai tendance à dire que s'il est
antisémite c'est qu' il n'est pas il
peut pas être l'oeuvre d'un fou sinon ça
serait pas un crime antisémite et en
même temps nous expliquent les experts
du combien ses fans ou le redire à cinq
ou sept experts ont jugé qu'il était
effectivement fou alors en même temps
j'ai du mal à croire qu'on puisse être
antisémite sans être vous de toute façon
déjà c'est un peu comme le terroriste on
dit toujours céder le solitaire c'est
des fous pas s'ils sont fous c'est pour
ça qu'ils d'un terroriste l'auteur de
l'attentât dans l'allier on voit bien
aussi qu'il y avait des ddd z
oui atteint psychiatrique et d'ailleurs
pardon parce qu'il sent dans le froid
dans la loi sécurité
on va essayer de faire en sorte que sans
violer le secret médical
les psychiatres puissent apporter leur
témoignage à la police qui est
intéressant juste à propos de
psychiatrie parce que l'opinion publique
est toujours prête à s'offusquer
critique est toujours décision de
justice mais le traoré l'assassin a
peut-être été reconnu irresponsable et
impossible à juger
il est quand même parti dans un ce qu'on
appelle une unité pour malades
difficiles qui est un truc pire que la
pire des prisons un hôpital
psychiatrique pour que pour dengue dans
son genre donc c'est pas non plus
on l'a pas libéré on n'a pas mis dans
n'est pas en train de gazouiller dans
les champs et dans un établissement y
perdure et tant mieux fallu deux le
mérite mais ce que veut dire c'est pas
allé n'est pas dans une clinique c'est
pas on est beaucoup plus proche de volée
mais il n'y a pas eu de jugement et
encombrement mais il est temps qu'ils y
sont présents et des pires qu'en prison
il ya eu une interview du procureur
général près la cour de cassation
françois molins qui dit la réponse du
moins cette interview fait fait vraiment
bien le le tour des choses en substance
ici encore d'une part on peut pas parler
comme ça rapidement aux slogans ou en
petites phrases sur une question est
infiniment complexe donc ça demanderait
là pour le coup vraiment du fond les
choses sont pas si simple que cela et
d'autre part la cour de cassation c'est
à dire le juge ici a suivi de mon point
de vue un traitement relativement
injuste parce que ça a été dit et je
pense compris depuis le jugent de façon
générale même si là encore c'est pas si
simple que cela
il appuie de la loi alors ils
l'appliquent en l'interprétant une la
musique parfois dans ses angles morts ou
dans ses silences
mais de manière générale le juger c'est
la tradition la tradition française est
plutôt la bouche de la loi et donc un
projet de loi est paraît-il paraît-il
sur le métier est à l'oeuvre
on verra mais en tout cas cette question
elle n'est elle ne l est infiniment plus
plus plus complices que la façon dont on
la présentait très souvent allez on va
passer
troisième thème donc la situation
sanitaire très rapidement j'ai une
question à vous poser est ce que est ce
que macro et bolton euros c'est pas le
même combat finalement
[Musique]
c'est vrai que pendant un moment il y
ait eu les gentils les mets sont les
gentils c'était ce qui mettait la santé
comme priorité avant l'économie et les
méchants étaient 30 sécurité l'économie
avant pour la santé or depuis qu'on sait
que ce virus est compliquée qui a déjà
des variants qui vont nous embêter
probablement pour d'être des années j'ai
l'impression qu'on change de point de
vue il n'ya quel vaccin en plus mais que
et on va annoncer probablement pour la
mimi la rouverture des magasins une une
vie sociale peut-être plus semblable à
ce qu'on connaissait avant le virus est
ce que finalement c'est pas les missions
qui ont gagné parce qu'avoir vous dites
et l'économie avant la santé mais c'est
surtout ce qui est important c'est de la
liberté avant la santé c'est ça le vrai
débat enfin c'est pas tant l'économie
c'est la liberté monsieur tout à fait
sur la ligne de compte peuvent ils
disent la liberté c'est ce qu'a plus
important la liberté de voyager liberté
de faire ce qu'on veut et là on est dans
une époque totalement liberticide
on a été le président macron était de
vue visiblement l'otage au départ d'une
caste médical qui voulait prendre les
décisions qui voulait gouverner
heureusement il semble s'en être libéré
vous interromps parce que vous allez
rapidement il ne reste plus beaucoup de
temps
je suis pas d'accord si je suis d'accord
sur le fait que liberté c'est évidemment
ce qui est le plus fondamental ce je
suis pas d'accord sur le fait que le
président dacquois ont été plus plus ou
moins liberticide que d'autres parce que
quand j'ai l'air la décision prise
on n'a pas fermé et très sport comme un
cette semaine ces messieurs je rappelle
que nous recevons les écoles à la
situation sanitaire est pire qu'au
moment nous avons décidé de fermer ya
trois semaines donc c'est quand même
tout ça assez surprenant ça participe
quand même de la volonté de maintenir
une économie active au dehors des
risques sanitaires
on est passé peut-être une étape
va-t-elle de baidoa voilà on en a un peu
assez on a envie de reprendre un peu la
vie quoi et c'est pour ça que le fameux
en même temps est précieux à la fois les
mesures de soutien et le plan de relance
avec un axe sur la solidarité sur
l'environnement ça c'est extrêmement
précieux c'est embêtant c'est ça va être
précieux pour la suite par rapport à
bôle sonar ou aucune mesure c'est une
hécatombe ça c'est scandaleux aussi donc
ça c'est important de le rappeler
justement et cette irresponsabilité au
brésil ses fans manceau pour conclure au
pour conclure c'est toujours périlleux
avec murray toujours affaire ben tout
est toujours à faire de conciliation de
juste mesure la décision parfaite
n'existe pas là tout ce que tout cela
manifeste c'est que et bien il faut
concilier les impératifs politiques pas
seulement économique avec les impératifs
de santé publique quant à bolton arrow
enfin c'est de mon point de vue le degré
zéro de ce que peut être un responsable
politique
oui je crois non quand je disais même
combat je verrais que je le comparerais
pas tout à fait mais c'est vrai qu'on a
l'impression qu'il ya là l'idée
peut-être qu'on va vivre longtemps avec
ce virus et qu'à un moment il va falloir
vivre autrement qu'en étant confiné et
qu'en étant du brevet rivaux libre
j'espère que la consommation de cet
hiver avec beaucoup plus d'efficacité et
c'est vrai que gérant rappelle et c'est
vrai qu'elle va de 5 qui songe quand
même beaucoup de choses
merci infiniment à tous les cas voilà
puis on se retrouve la semaine prochaine
pour un nouveau numéro de paf merci à
tous
[Musique]